so gentlemen as you know one of the most
um
well-known food items from japan
i was trying to figure out what i was
trying to say but one of the most
well-known food items from japan
is of course the jelly doughnuts aka
actually
you took me back the onigiri uh which if
you've seen
if you've basically watched any anime
you've seen characters eating onigiri
the rice balls
this is this is basically the closest we
get to an actual japanese sandwich
because it's a
rice sandwich basically right this is a
wait wait
oh okay oh oh my god i did not
where's the seaweed where is the seaweed
the best part it's like
it's like the hot dog wrapper right yeah
the best part of a hot dog is the crunch
yeah
right what is that it is a scrilled
salmon onigiri oh i have a grilled
salmon one as well okay
we have also a grilled salmon salmon
onigiri so yeah as you know me and gone
actually ate onigiri this is actually
one of them that i was eating and it was
quite delicious as much as i was
complaining uh show business honestly
that is that is my favorite onigiri to
get so from
lawsons i've never seen that one from
i mean from all of the places gone now
lawson's
like every good big brain company has
their own
product line specifically for onigiri
they have the bit the basic [ __ ] on a
geary yeah it's like a hundred yen now
this [ __ ] is like 190 yen
that's the premium you can't even see it
that's how premium
honestly i i will stan um 7-eleven hot
foods
and fried foods i don't i don't stand
it's not serious
this is the most depressing looking
onigiri i've ever seen
i'm sorry it's it's like it's like it's
just put the condom on wrong
they put the condom on sideways instead
of on top now let me gentlemen let me
show you what a good onigiri
okay actually it looks the same it's
just
it's just it's just the bigger condom oh
no
that's how it should look look at that
that's just the bigger condom that's a
beautiful
honestly it's beautiful because every
bite you get you get a bit of seaweed
okay but here's the thing that's the
thing i think here's the thing that
differentiates between a good onion gear
and banana here it's the rice to insides
ratio 100
100 yes if there's like if the first
bite you bite into an onigiri and you
immediately hit the inside that's a good
one
yeah too fair a lot of the cheap ones or
even sometimes like if they've just
filled it not quite right that one time
you do just get like four bites in
you're like where is the [ __ ] where's
the feeling uh i gotta ask
do you boys actually eat on a gear
anymore yes yeah i still do you do i i
gave up
i do whenever i need to quit when i
whenever i literally need a quick snack
yeah i'm sure i'm just never in the mood
for a block of carbs you know what i
mean that's the problem and like
there's not enough filling i'd rather
wait and yet you get the [ __ ]
microwavable gu dogs
that's if like i want to [ __ ] i want
to pick out like
i i haven't i haven't had a goo dog in a
long time just like that she's
dreadful honestly because sometimes
sometimes i miss my lunch and i have
like a filming or something
and i just need to fill up my stomach as
quickly as possible and that's when i
get
just like one onigiri that lasts me
until dinner and it does everything it
needs to do what is your favorite
filling of the only year so there's
different flavors that you could have in
it
normally all fish there is sometimes
grilled chicken but honestly
i'm not a fan of the chicken don't get
it like because the good part about the
fish one is that normally like seeps
into the rest of the area yeah the
chicken one just is a ball i'd have to
say the
tuna it's probably my favorite as well i
actually you are holding my favorite one
which is the salmon belly
it's really really good premium uh
salmon
uh i in terms of the chicken how do you
guys feel about the onigiri where it
doesn't really have a filling
it's just kind of like the the grilled
grilled rice with grilled chicken or
whatever i used to eat those when i was
little
but as i got older i was like nah i just
want i want something more like
yeah yeah it feels like satisfying yeah
fake meal i don't know why
um but yeah i don't know why when i
first visited japan i [ __ ] all i ate
was like onigiri i think
everyone's like because you're like oh
my god i'm in japan i don't eat the
japanese things i can't get this at home
i get a sandwich at home yeah but then
when i started living here i'm like
yo the sandwiches are pretty [ __ ]
bothered because i've tried these
sandwiches and they're like nearly the
same price
what am i doing man and sandwich is
easier to eat because sometimes onigiri
falls apart if you like if you're you
know sometimes you're doing it right
yeah yeah like i didn't give it to me i
never eat onigiri as a meal like if i'm
having a lunch i never pick
onigiri as the lunch onigiri is a
convenience if i need to stuff myself
and have it not taste awful
i just realized there's like no way for
us to like share yeah
to be fair i've never tried the family
mart branded i have never tried the
seven onigiri
i've had this one before and it's good
and i'm just gonna do a bite just to
prove that it's good
again oh look at that immediately wait
like okay how many how deep would i have
to bite draken to get the filling jay
all right i just bit a whole ton of rice
and it didn't even have any seaweed
i hit like one one millimeter of first
per
let me give it bite i mean how deep this
do you yeah yeah
that's i already broke into salmon yeah
look at that
mine mine like my salmon actually has
like a little bit like soy sauce in it
so the soy sauce kind of seeped into
the rice a little bit that's really
flavorful that's good that's nice fatty
salmon this is this is awful this is all
foreign
honestly this this this is the most
depressing looking grilled salmon 1711
[ __ ] okay so we can say family martin
lawson have got their branded onigiri
down pretty
down part yeah if you want the best
onigiri from a chain i would highly
recommend
i would highly recommend lawson's as
well lawson's especially the grilled
salmon belly
that is [ __ ] bomb